so the other night my wonderful wife
Lizzie shows me this screenshot or
actually he shows me on her phone look
at this isn't this the way it's not
supposed to be done
that's right Lizzie it is not the way
it's supposed to be done it blows my
mind screenshot
it blows my mind in 2012 that brands
we're now in 2012 that brands continue
to think that these platforms are to
push down the throat of the consumer so
their little sheep and they actually
listen and push on your stuff that this
lowest common denominator that's what it
is
the LCD of the way companies are
marketing on these new platforms is
borderline sad it reminds me why the
creativity and the skill sets that it
took to promote in the push platforms of
the prior generation are to be
questioned heavily and most of all I'm
just I'm just begging people please
understand that pushing your messages
down the consumers throats and asking
them to do what you want for them is not
the way to use these new platforms these
sites are out there because we can
actually have some sort of communication
I continue to see stuff like this I
can't believe I'm still making videos
about this crap in 2012 but when the own
network Oprah Winfrey Network when the
person that most embodied having a
relationship with their community on the
old platform of television is doing it
so poorly so pissed poorly on the new
platform it just it just forced me to
make this video I'm just you know I'm
not even sure what I'm trying to
accomplish with this video
I guess I'm hoping I'm praying that I'm
so angry and so ridiculous on this video
that somebody might be like oh crap
maybe we're doing this wrong I mean guys
please